the historic heat that jeff was talking
about in the west is blamed for what may
be
record-breaking hospitalizations in
washington state
hospitals report nearly 1800 emergency
room visits for heat-related illness
in this past week at least 100 people
have died in the west and that includes
a farm worker in oregon
the punishing heat is bad news for all
farm workers in that region
lilia luciano looks at efforts to
protect them
for nearly a week farm workers at this
southern washington state cherry farm
have faced temperatures as high
as 113 degrees this is a crisis
it's an emergency we followed volunteers
with the united farm workers union
as they handed out cold drinks
and explained the signs of heat
exhaustion and heat stroke
jolanda carrion told us farmworkers who
are typically paid by the amount of
crops they pick
are often hesitant to take breaks what
does it feel like
you start feeling nauseous this heat
wave has been different
it's been a lot harder many including
this 11 year old named juan
start their shift as early as 3 a.m to
avoid the heat
and until what time are you working
i don't really know now the united farm
workers union is pushing for safeguards
like those already in place in
california
we are demanding that the governor
implement emergency rules for this heat
crisis for our farm workers here in
washington state
they need cold water they need rest
breaks and they need
shade in the fields
volunteers also honored farm workers who
have lost their lives
including sebastian francisco perez an
oregon farm worker from guatemala who
died last weekend
his death raises concerns about the heat
in the weeks and months ahead
one thing that worries me the most is
that there's children out here working
and that a lot of the workers don't feel
comfortable calling 9-1-1
that was lilia luciano reporting from
washington state